hey what's up y'all I'm dr. Atala Brown
emergency physician and this is the
breakdown first up we got Scarface all
right in emergency medicine we deal with
blast injuries all the timers things
that come from these types of mass
casualty events the fact that they were
that close to the blast is worrisome to
me Barrow trauma to the ears or
pressurized injury to the ear because
it's a tight space right and then you've
got other things such as what's flying
through the air because of a blast
so shrapnel matter from the buildings in
the body actually being thrown in the
air is another degree of trauma so
imagine being lifted off the ground and
then slammed to the ground with this
tremendous force I don't know if they
would even get back up right away if not
it had the ears ringing alright stop I
don't see a guy being able to continue
to shoot after that specifically because
where it hit him so he got hit left
upper thorax area so like left chest
heart you have lungs anytime you hit
someone center mast they're gonna have a
very poor outcome bleeding a lot or he
should be able to talk like that
I mean he's taking at least four rounds
that I've seen the first one itself was
lethal so I don't know how he could
continue to have this monologue in real
life I mean this guy definitely is not
standing he's gonna pass out in any more
that's it that is it that is it it's a
wrap I mean he was talking and then all
of a sudden $0.50 that's it gets hit all
over the chest but I just was thinking
about like as I'm rolling this in my
head if he is still on cocaine look he
would have bled faster one of the side
effects or the actual main effect of
taking cocaine it's a simple mimetic
which is like a drug that boosts all of
your your senses up so it would benefit
him to have taken cocaine and to already
be in this fight or flight type of
scenario but if you are hitting a vital
artery I don't know if that would be a
real thing to see someone go this far in
the fight most shotgun wounds are Lee he
gets hit one time all those other guys
shot him about ninety seven times in
nothing happened apparently but this one
it is the one that good night see next
up we have us don't trust people who
walk like that alright stop that's real
the way that she got stabbed through the
back of the hand I would be concerned
that after this she couldn't make a fist
very realistic injury something that I
see extremely you know often in the
emergency department I take my hat off
to her to continue to fight after this
[Music]
not gonna be able to grab that that's
just what I believe my grabbing that I
don't know she'd be able to create
enough force to hold it if thumb might
be okay unless the blood supply is
compromised but as you watching there's
like no blood dripping behind her if
you've ever seen a hand injury it bleeds
like crazy I'm talking about is
consistent flow and if it's an artery
which is what I think she probably had
severed that artery is going to continue
to put out blood like high output she
wouldn't be able to continue this far
without us seeing evidence of the injury
[Music]
whoa all right these wounds that go
through the abdomen except for this one
is at the level where I think it may
have gone through part of the diaphragm
and it may even go into the back so I
mean let's play a little bit longer oh
yeah so it's all the way through here I
don't have to tell you you see it but
for it to go front to back it's possibly
affecting spinal nerves she's not gonna
be able to walk from or move anything
from that level below I'd be more
concerned about at that angle what part
of the heart does she hit like I think
she may have just severed her aorta
maybe that diaphragm I think she pierced
through so I don't see being able to
even make the motion to breathe in in
and whistle because that rod went
straight through both the fixation with
the handcuffs that's pretty brutal man I
got a problem with where movies that
have this like sound of crunching it's
not like that easy to go through all of
those structures and all of a sudden
magically get two vertebrae and just I
don't know if that happens like that so
I think that the crunch is more than
likely from something more anterior in
the front of the neck not so much
posterior
all right the next book we're gonna see
whiplash okay look why don't you just
tell Fletcher that I copied your mother
stop there's a lot of lessons to be
learned just from this part motor
vehicle accidents like one of the top
the leading causes of death in young
people you're talking on the phone
totally distracted driving a car and
they're setting it up just like it
happened when it comes into my emergency
department I'm sorry yeah I worry off
the top about him being thrown and
joseline in the cars if car flips you've
got an entire different set of things
that you're worried about loss of
consciousness head injury so his head
struck something in the car glass broken
that projectile if the car is basically
bent in on the side why the driver his
lower body is entrapped he's lucky I
mean he's this is what I'm talking about
this is a super common thing that we get
an emergency department they will bring
us someone who was in a rollover
accident and they come mangled
I mean seatbelts are extremely helpful
and try to reduce injuries like this but
that type of deceleration or quick
shearing force if it wasn't an airbag
that hit him or the steering wheel that
hit him then it may have been inside of
the car itself like a coup contrecoup
the phrase that they use which basically
is like some cool French word which
means that the head strikes on one side
and impacts and then the the opposite
side will also impact he may have struck
something on one end and the force threw
him in the opposite direction he struck
the wallet car again I would not be
getting up out of the car a lot of times
what happens on the scene is some will
get up and then they go down immediately
because they didn't realize that they
had an intracranial bleed you think
everything is cool if they go down we
call that a lucid interval I would
definitely not recommend standing
straight up vertically walking around
because I'm worried about him hasn't
bleeding that's not visible I'm worried
about his neck having an injury in a
vertebral
align me do not move but if you're
worried about the vehicle blowing up man
crawl Lieutenant Dan it out out out the
body woke up and said we were just in a
car accident yes you were and that's why
I don't think he could continue the
performance he would have difficulty
trying to hold the sticks that match
grip wouldn't be as easy him trying to
to like keep along with things and hear
things all of those senses could be
compromised by pulling blood inside
things
next up Kill Bill Vol tooth if you're
trapped inside a coffin oxygen is going
to be an immediate concern I think that
you'll only be able to survive like a
matter of minutes
in this situation her core temperature
might be a little bit elevated trying to
figure out what's going on in this
situation the cool thing about people
who are this highly trained sometimes
they're able to lower their heart rate
and lower their body temperature the
core temperature so that's like upper
echelon type of warrior stuff she might
be able to do that I still don't see
that giving her a considerable time
advantage you can't make more oxygen
exist in this space the fact that your
rebreathing carbon dioxide would make it
a little bit less likely for you to do
this type of focus that too
punch train boxers or train fighters
know exactly which knuckles to strike
with and how to limit the likelihood of
a fracture any other random person off
the street who was trying to punch their
way through a coffin one I don't think
they'd be able to get that far - they're
definitely gonna break a hand
I'd expect them to have fractures of the
ring finger and the pinky finger because
they don't know how to throw a punch
properly
whereas heard she probably has already
had so many fractures that the bone
itself that's formed in a certain way to
be strengthened so that she wouldn't the
fracture Hannity another thing that
doesn't make sense to me she's deep
underneath the ground right so dirts
coming in not air just more dirt so I
don't know if you get a great benefit of
oxygen from having more minerals dropped
inside on both hand reaches through the
earth yeah that's probably the most
realistic part of this whole thing is
how much she wanted that oxygen when she
got a hook this I know this sisters uh
was struggling down there so congrats to
you alright so the next movie Austin
Powers The Spy Who shagged me
yeah
[Music]
this is like a very classic injury right
it usually means that the person can't
move their limbs below the level of the
injury and have some sensory deficits so
I'd like to see what happens as far as
like how they display this clearly
[Music]
wait a minute okay so it wasn't enough
that she got a knife in the bed
[Laughter]
unfortunately I've never been in this
situation to know exactly how this plays
out but any high-powered weapon like
that has the ability to make bullets go
through bodies so I'd be worried that
Austin or they've taken at least two
wait a minute no injuries from the front
of her body yes
no no
[Music]
now she does the injuries to even try to
talk about how realistic it is I feel
foolish but she took an RPG round
straight to the body and Austin's
untouched but nothing fazes my man I
think the death plain we realize we know
what would happen I love the fact that
she's in here still talking to him why
they fall just a little char you know
just a little singed
mmm yeah she's definitely gone after
that fall and he might actually have an
injury to that's probably one of the
most misunderstood things people think
that if I fall trying to land on my feet
you'll end up with a lot of compression
fractures that way bilateral ankle
fractures the vertebrae itself from the
axial load or the load of the force
going down onto the vertebrae or come up
from the ground that you land on I would
probably try my best to fall on like one
part of the body and try to make sure
that you don't hit your head so those
are the areas that I've next movie we're
gonna watch I know where this is going
basically someone is gonna freeze
honestly two people should freeze what
you're dealing with in hypothermia is
essentially like blood flow that is no
longer going to areas where it needs to
go to keep the tissue alive when the
body goes into this mode it's trying to
conserve as much heat and as much blood
flow as possible so it'll divert it
towards vital organs like the brain and
the heart but the extremities they get
frostbite and eventually you have
complete disruption of the tissues and
they may not be viable after that I'm
glad he's still talking I'd be worried
about the quiet people
he has uncontrolled shivering the other
things that I think is a little bit
unrealistic is he's able to continue to
think things through like that mentation
is something that goes when you're
starting to be more hypothermic so the
fact that he's talking is a good thing I
just don't know if he'd be able to move
as freely as he's moving now if it's
that cold
this is what I was talking about this
face right here I'd expect that face a
lot earlier on if it's that cold the
mental status is starting to wax and
wane because the only thing that's being
perfused really is parts of the brain
and now that's going
I would also worry about is the the
heart rhythm regular when you start to
drop the core body temperature to this
level your heart is freaking out at 28
degrees Fahrenheit I just think that
you're gonna start to freeze a lot
sooner five minutes max definitely not
an hour in this water let him go let him
go this is the last thing that I would
do is roll into some water I just don't
see her having full action in those
extremities if she was able to withstand
this tundra level cold maybe she could
blow the whistle but no I just don't
definitely not loud enough to get the
guy to come back up next we have John
wick chapter 3
he knows what's coming oh he has to die
if you watch the movie you know that
he's got like these special liners
inside of his jacket it's possible that
he may be able to sustain a couple shots
like that from a handgun even his
reaction is we like to double over after
those shots we watch a couple other
movies and get fazed by being shot where
is he in this movie like doubles over I
think that this is realistic
so can we rewind it a little bit so two
three four stop man all of those
different hits means that he had blunt
trauma in each of those locations no the
father's breaking him his ribs wrapped
on the bar at one point another part of
his hip struck the dumpster and did
finally head and shoulders so you're
talking about vessels still shearing
because they're stopped abruptly you're
talking about bones that have to deal
with that force and they're not made to
bend and be malleable you might fracture
the skull but you can also cause the
brain to jostle it's so many different
injuries in this scene I don't even
think I could just start to enumerate
them off the bat he's John wick I mean
at the end of the day you know he's
getting back up with a broken pelvis and
spine away
up next to the campaign okay so people
own exotic animals and I've seen
everything from snakebites to Gila
monster attacks common location actually
common mechanisms you know someone
handling the snake trying to act cool
and then all of a sudden snake go snake
on them and that's what happened that's
kind of realistic somebody once you get
bit it's is every curse word in the book
I would be worried about the person who
talks talks and then all of a sudden
starts to just trail off because that
means that's the effect of the venom is
starting to take off
yeah becomes a neuropathic yep I love
how they change to fisheye lens to
basically simulate that he is altered
and that's realistic other things that
would happen I mean he may fall out have
a seizure if you have recently gotten
bitten and you start to have this
altered mental status you may run
straight through a window like that I
don't think that that's uh completely
unrealistic the next movie Casino Royale
he just got poisoned and because he's
James Bond the cars tricked out with a
defibrillator like AED right there in
the - looks like he's trying to capture
his pulse or a rhythm I mean if I'm
looking for somebody's heart activity
I'm going to place leads around the
heart I don't think that this is
realistic unless he's trying to put an
IV access into his governor seven
stay calm and don't interrupt because
you'll be dead within two minutes unless
you do exactly what I tell you he's
starting to sweat and call the gif
releases
[Music]
now this is what I was talking about as
far as you have to place somewhere on
the body those leads in order to
effectively distribute a shock tricular
tachycardia did you talk so pause go
back a little bit this means that his
ventricles the part of the heart that's
responsible for forcing the blood around
the body they're beating more rapidly
than normal this is an indication to
deliver a shock or to cardiovert
somebody so that's what I think is about
to happen I don't know how realistic it
is for somebody to distribute a shock to
themselves I mean maybe that's just a
bad ass thing that only James Bond can
do people who are in this type of
tachyarrhythmia are unable to like whole
things I don't think that is realistic
that someone be able to just push a
button and deliver a shock to their self
okay pause this is not real
obviously it's some movie magic they put
some numbers on top of some stuff I
would expect the arrhythmia to be a lot
higher 150 160 180s most of us gets to
135 just from a brisk walk or jogging 97
I'm assuming down at the bottom is his
oxygen usually through a pulse ox on a
fingertip which we didn't see him place
push the red button now he passed out so
I think that's realistic a lot of times
patients will have these types of
reactions in the city
[Music]
so that's realistic
you are literally rebooting the heart
from scratch like a cold boot and so
when I talk to patients afterwards
they feel like they died for a second I
mean technically they were right because
it was entirely jump-started that is a
normal reaction for someone to kind of
like jolt and then all of a sudden come
back to next childhood favorite home
alone - I can't say that I have seen a
lot of bricks - the heads any object
with considerable mass that strikes you
can lead to a concussion like this
imagine putting like a boiled egg inside
of a jar with a little bit of water
that's essentially what the brain is
like inside the head and then it's
striking against walls of the skull is
similar to that egg that soft part of
the egg striking the glass and it can
lead to nausea vomiting confusion
dizziness he's gonna have that within
the next day look see see this is called
diplopia right so he sees two different
objects and when I have those patients
come in after head injuries I'll say do
you see one of me or two of me boom you
get two bricks today you basically
you're gonna stay there for 24 hours if
I have anything to do with it not
because you have an injury but because
you shouldn't be doing anything to get
hit by two bricks like that's what I'm
worried about
we'll keep you around all right dude
just stay down just a good night like
Kevin is incredibly accurate in terms of
his own abilities it looks like to do is
get struck in the same place I'd be
worried that he has like a small
fracture in the front part of the tail
like his frontal bone or even one of the
sinuses being fractured can't even save
all right he did take a tumble but did
he actually black out if he blacked out
this is a guy that I want to get on the
Cask ante balloons possum
one it can actually be the person blacks
out because of the impact a repeat fall
could be because less blood flow to that
portion of the brain because it's
leaking into another space these are all
in the scenario of like struck by a
brick I don't know I've never been hit
by bricks so I'm gonna keep that a
streak going
that was a breakdown with GQ thank y'all
for watching
I
[Music]